here
is still this matter
to see what this threat consisted of,
the truth is that the Mexican avocado has already woken up
anyway,
and what is
this reviewing what is it about
in all this
there are also many
political economic interests there is competition
they do not want
the avocado  Mexican not
to enter the US will prevail
due to its quality in the US there are other countries
interested in selling the avocado
to President Carlos in a news way,
because radically changing a little bit of issues
this
weekend the Secretary of
Agriculture announces
a subject of the  avocado there is a complaint
there by supposedly from the
North American instance they are lobbying,
that is, they are
looking for senators, they are looking for
public officials
to the agencies
to be putting obstacles
if it is not for this it is because of the
vaquita porpoises because of the dolphins but in reality
there is always behind
a commercial economic interest
or
a political attitude
in any case we
and
We are seeing this, we have a very good
relationship
with the government